what writing advice has helped you the
most
that's a good question the writing
advice that's helped me the most
is actually very very simple
um it came from
a friend of mine who's himself a
a fantastic writer director who's
written and directed films that we've
seen films on netflix i mean big big
movies
um and the writing advice was
only keep writing
that was it and this was coming from a
friend
who you know just was
trying to impart on me that you know the
way that
he broke in or the way that he was able
to really
elevate his career was when he
wrote a script that everybody wanted
and he was able to attach himself
as a director um
so the advice was was very simple just
keep writing
and it's something i think about often
and it's something i think about
to this day and i and i feel like that
goes a little bit to what i was saying
earlier about perseverance it really
goes i i think it speaks to that a
little bit because
it is that that attitude i think
that's i've seen be successful for so
many people i've i've seen this work
where it's just
you really always have to keep doing it
and i think
i think it could apply to most
things in the entertainment industry not
just writing i mean
acting or directing i think really
whatever you want to do and it's
it's the simplest thing in the world
but it's just something worth
remembering i think
keep writing keep acting keep
directing keep pushing forward or
if you want to be you know whatever it
is you want to do if you want to do
costume design or production design if
if those are really what you're
interested in
um cinematography keep
doing it i think and i think the more
you do it
the better you'll get and i think the
results will just sort of start to speak
for themselves
you know and it also goes i think it
speaks a little bit to
what i was saying earlier about you know
making
shorts with friends or making web series
of it
if you keep doing it and you do it
enough
you sort of start to see
i mean you you definitely start to see
your work improve but i think you sort
of
um start to to to
[Music]
see that you can kind of push it a
little bit further or you can go a
little bit further next time so
yeah that was just a very simple piece
of writing advice and it's something i
always remember and it's something i
always say to myself
just keep writing so if you were going
to take that advice and say turn it into
a script
and say you and a bunch of writers are
hunting through the forest and there's
this cave and the secret of life is
in this this one cave and and you go to
this box
and there it is just just keep writing
keep reading would you be disappointed
it's so easy or
it's actually not that easy maybe
it's like a goonies adventure yeah and
then you find out here it is
trying to put myself in that place wait
a minute guys we found it
uh yeah maybe if the journey was
difficult and we had to do like the
goonies and there was booby traps and
stuff
sure yeah i might be a little
disappointed
but uh but i mean uh
luckily i didn't have to do all of that
i think we just went out to lunch but
uh but uh that was it
you know keep keep doing it keep writing
screenplays keep teaching yourself how
to write screenplays
and you know write the next one and
write the next one and just
you will improve i promise and maybe the
positive is
if we if we want to put a positive spin
is that it's not
it's not rocket science but it's it's
hard to show up for the process
i think so i really do i i think i think
you know all of this stuff or anything
that i've done in my career acting
filmmaking producing writing
um no i agree it's it's not rocket
science it's
it really is you know it's hard work
it's a lot of it's a lot of
um you know it is a lot of
you know uh trial and error
um and it's a lot of just stick to it
and it's a lot of being able to kind of
pivot i think also is something that is
really
um i think important
uh for people to be able to you know if
something's
not going the way you want or if if you
you know if it's not going
according to plan exactly being able to
kind of like switch gears and
maybe attack it from a different angle
but i get the sense you're very flexible
that you kind of like
if the current's going one way and you
see the current is taking you that way
you go okay i'll swim that way
absolutely yeah i i think i am very
flexible and
i think i do sort of go with the flow a
little bit
and um it's really interesting because
you know as i've said over my career
over so many years i mean i've been
involved with
many projects and even now to this day
i'm producing
multiple things and and they are
all kind of different and i'm just sort
of learning to go with it and you sort
of learn something new on everyone which
is you know it's all a learning
experience like you know podcasting i'm
learning about that now and
i'm learning about docuseries and i'm
learning about
you know narrative television episodic
television
um so yeah i think you do i think it's
really
excellent to be able to go with the flow
and i think it's really interesting too
because i think
now we're seeing you know
more than ever maybe more than i've ever
witnessed as we're seeing a lot of walls
kind of
breaking down you know we're seeing you
know it used to be like
there was film and there was television
and you could do
one or you could do the other and now
it's like
you know you see actors from films doing
television and vice versa television
doing film and
people are doing podcasts now there's a
there's a big push in the
the podcasting space um there's the
web there's you know web series digital
series
um there's streaming so i feel like
especially now and we've talked about
this earlier but i do
consider myself kind of you know the
lifer filmmaker like i'm always just
involved in many different things i
think now more than ever just the walls
are breaking down and it's it's
you know you don't have to pick what
you're gonna do you can do it all
um but i just think the only
um you know the the only rule now
i would say is just make it excellent
that's it what would you say are your
writing weaknesses
if i was this guru up in the mountains
the same
you know hunt for the for the answers
and and then
the magical sort of guru lives in this
one
castle and he's going to help you and
you present to him
sure um this is my writing
weakness yeah i i i i
you know sure please please take it away
from me for sure please help me
sure so uh i've got a good one for that
okay um
so i would say if i had to say something
was my writing weakness
i would say my writing weakness is
probably
um the big
sort of the big picture the big
story structure um
i find that i'm
best at or what i think i'm best at or
where i excel
and what i really like is sort of like
the dialogue
and i like sort of character you know
of closer character work like character
detail
dialogue stuff like that which is
kind of interesting because it speaks to
how i work with my writing partner and
wife sarah um
that she is sort of good at the
structure big picture you know
beginning end sort of overarching theme
and story and things like that and then
i
sort of think that sort of my
my um strong note to our team
is sort of the really detailed character
stuff and the dialogue stuff
so it's interesting because that's how
we kind of work together is that sarah
sort of
will plot everything out and sort of
looks at everything from
from the sort of like bird's eye view
and then when it's time to really get in
there and work on the
the crafting of the specific nuances of
a scene or the dialogue
um that's sort of where i excel and
that's
you know that's it's been a great
partnership um and that's
it's interesting because that's sort of
you know sarah and i
were producing partners we you know we
own our production company together
um and that's kind of how we work on
everything
you know she's sort of the the uh big
picture person and i sort of
do more of the like detailed um
[Music]
sort of like specific stuff so if you
were going to this this
this guru and he says okay you have five
minutes or whatever and
please help me become better at the
overall theme
or or and what if you said
don't worry about it find someone that's
your equal opposite equal
or i mean is that something that you're
happy that you're good with the little
nuance and the
and the dialogue and little
idiosyncrasies maybe of characters that
make them fun
yes i mean it's interesting like i don't
um you know because i do work with my
my wife and because we are writing
partners and
and and producing partners um
i you know i'm very comfortable sticking
to
i i really do like to work on the
dialogue i think that's very fun for me
and
in sort of characters going back and
forth and how people
talk to each other um so i don't feel
like
it's um it's like a uh
something that that i think i consider
too much of a weakness in myself because
i have that other person however i could
see for somebody you know for for
somebody who's writing on their own
where yeah they might want to
you know if they feel very strongly
about one thing sure they might want to
get
you know better at something else but i
think i'm really
fortunate that um you know we can come
at it from both
both sides um but uh
but i think that also speaks to just
you know i like to work with a writing
partner
for me you know even before i was
writing with sarah i would always write
with one of my friends
it was never really just me
um i think i'd maybe written one
screenplay
years ago by myself and i didn't really
like it
you know because writing is a very
solitary thing
you know you're really by yourself for a
long time
um and so it's very nice
for me to have a partner um
just you know now it's it's my wife but
even before that
was a close friend always
so you know i would say for people who
are thinking about maybe getting a
writing partner
i would say look for a writing partner
that does have those strengths that
maybe you don't have you know if you're
really great at
the story the big picture and you're not
so great at dialogue
if you if you're looking for a writing
partner look for someone who is great at
dialogue or
vice versa if you're great at the
dialogue look for somebody who's great
at the
you know the big structural things that
um
that maybe you're lacking on i think
that's i think that's great advice
is your antenna always up since you are
great at dialogue and maybe observation
or nuance or whatever is your when
you're i know right now where you've
been
home for a year and a half but when you
do go to let's say
a brand name coffee shop we don't have
to say the exact name but when you're in
line or whatever
are you are your ears up are you you
know because you can hear some
fascinating conversations in l.a
uh to answer your question am i
always listening yes i am i'm going to
go home and write about this
no i'm kidding okay um no
no to be serious yes anywhere we go i'm
always listening and for me um
it's it's interesting because
i feel like whenever we do write and
whenever i am writing the
dialogue or character detail
or anything like that i really do always
try to
personalize it and think about
people that i've heard or people that
i've met or people that i've interacted
with or maybe a story from my past
but it really always helps me
to to yeah to to
to personalize it because then i think
it it feels authentic
or it feels real for me and i think that
comes out
in the dialogue um so yeah i'm always
always on always listening
always paying attention to people and
it's also interesting because it's like
a
sort of a a thing if you like to do that
i like to just meet people random people
i like to talk to
you know if somebody wants to if a
stranger on the street
starts talking to me i will talk to them
or
whoever it is you know i'm very
friendly i guess you could say because i
do i like to just
take in everything because i know at
some point
i'll be able to use it
you